اسمح لي انا اسال عن موقف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لطالما كانت تقول
امريكا بانه قضيه السلام والاستقرار في
الشرق الاوسط قضيه مهمه بالنسبه لها
وبالنهايه هي ستكون مستفيده باي شكل من
الاشكال لماذا توقف السعي الامريكي عن
ايجاد
حاله استقرار داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه او
بين الجانبين الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
ة داخل الولايات المتحده نعم وكما ذكرتي
فان السياسه المعلنه
للادارات الامريكيه
المتتاليه كانت لدعم فكره تحقيق الاستقرار
بين الفلسطيني والاسرائيليين ولكن
الولايات المتحده لما تستخدم اي سلطه لها
على اسرائيل ولا حتى الفلسطينيين ولكن
بشكل خاص على اسرائيل
الدعم الاقتصادي والدبلوماسي المستمر
اعتقد بان الوضع الحالي
اظهر وظهر مؤخرا عندما
حتى رئيس بايدن حكومه نتنهاء على عدم
الاستمرار بخططها
لتجاوز او
مساء الخاصه بالقضائي في فلسطين وتسببت
بالكثير من الجدل واستجابه لاحد وزراء
الاسرائيليين قال لا تهتم بشؤون اهتم
بشؤونك الخاصه
فالاداره الحاليه تريد ان
التحدث الشجاعه الداخليه اللي تواجه
اسرائيل بعضها هذه الحقائق التي تواجهها
ولا اتوقع بنا تقدم فيما يخص السلام